how different was his relationship with
trump versus biden
i was preoccupied during those things so
my understanding of is what you saw
in the papers as well i never thought
trump was
pro-putin i think
trump's foreign policy
and it's
true and it was true in russia it was
true everywhere it was true in north
korea was personal diplomacy he believed
i mean the the donald trump i know
believes that when he can look you in
the face and he can talk to you you'll
understand his resolve and if you
understand his resolve that ability to
understand it will allow for things to
happen uh you know from in
in in theory
moscow and putin he
there no russian invasions happened
anywhere during trump's presidency why
because i believe putin understood
trump wouldn't tolerate it um
and
so
what they talked about i have no idea
but i do know
that just like north korea
would rabble rattled the sabres before
trump was president they went quiet
after after trump met with kim jong-un
trump's conversations with putin putin
went quiet
um and
uh and even china i mean i happen to
think if if trump had been reelected i
think they would have finished the the
international tariff negotiations and
then you'd have seen a new kind of
approach on foreign policy with xi
jinping
by trump because he would have fixed
what he thought was the first problem
and then he'd be dealing with the
political relationship
all on a personal basis um it's so
i i don't know what trump and putin
talked about i just know the consequence
with the results of his presidency and
the results were very positive for
freedom-loving countries so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]